justin is with us Justin's in California
hi Justin how are you hey Nicole
sure what's up so we're here yeah I have
a convert dilemma that I'd like your
advice on so I am 30 years old single no
kids no wife debt-free and I have a
hundred and seventy-five thousand
dollars in savings so I've definitely
been a saver to say the least
my concern is I need to buy a new car
and I've ended up the same car since
high school and I'm looking at a car
that's $21,000 I'm looking to buy it in
cash it's a 2017 Mustang the only thing
is that there's about 45,000 miles on it
so one I'd like to get your opinion on
that and then to do you kind of have a
baseline for how much of somebody's
savings should go to a car if you pay in
cash no I just tell folks not to type
more than about half their annual income
in all the things that they own with
motors and wheels so all the things you
have with motors and wheels which if you
don't own anything but that one car it
would be that one car okay now what's
your income a hundred thousand okay so
that that this fits easily within that
dude you're a conservative guy you're a
saver you're looking at a used car you
make $100,000 a year you looking at a
good used car that's a cool car i buy
that car yeah yeah I definitely want to
like I said it keeps more of the miles
versus the cost of it uh I got a look at
that but I mean that's not that many
miles on a Mustang Mustang is a solid
product for it's building a good product
you're fine unless it's been racked out
or some some teenager been driving it
and burning the wheels off of it or
something no so this is the first time
this is the first owner of the car and
he's pretty much like 35 years old
you've been driving the car mostly
highway miles oh you're fine Justin I
don't have any I don't know I don't know
if that's what the car is worth or not
you'd have to look that up I'm not an
expert on mustang values but Mustang is
a great car again for its building a
good product I wouldn't worry about that
mileage at all I think you gotta buy
that car well the math works Justin so
you're good yeah absolutely